you
[Music]
hey welcome everyone
I'm delighted this afternoon to
introduce our AI distinguished lecturer
as Cynthia dork who many of you know
Cynthia is one of the most accomplished
technical women who I've ever been
around she has four fancy titles right
now she's the Gordon Mackay professor at
Harvard in the computer science
department she's also the Radcliffe
alumna professor at the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Studies and she's
an affiliate faculty at the Harvard Law
School in addition to that she's a
distinguished scientist at Microsoft
Research she was one of the inaugural
class of distinguished scientists here
about a decade or so ago maybe a little
bit more
Cynthia received her PhD at Cornell with
John Hoffman ANSI Lynch at MIT and then
went on to spend a fair amount of time
at IBM Almaden where she did a lot of
foundational work that I was not all
that familiar with until until earlier
today she the the morick I knew about
that she did there was something on rank
aggregation which was very important in
web search she also did work on
cryptography foundations as well as
proof of work which is one of the
underlying foundations of Bitcoin at MSR
she is well known for two other strands
of work one is on differential privacy
putting privacy on theoretical firm
ground and it's incredibly important
today and what she'll talk about with us
this afternoon is nascent more nascent
work on algorithmic fairness this work
and and her lifelong accomplishments
have been acknowledged by more prizes
than I named more prizes and they're the
fancy titles I mentioned at the outset
she's obviously a fellow of the ACM she
won the Dijkstra Prize more than a
decade ago she won the godel Prize she's
one of the very few people who are
members of both the National Academy and
National Academy of Engineering National
Academy of Science and National Academy
of Engineering she's an amazingly adept
scientist and one who picks problems
that have real practical impact which I
think is a really unique skill so with
that introduction I'd like to introduce
Cynthia who will tell us about some of
her work on algorithmic fairness thank
you very much for that gracious
introduction thank you for inviting me
Emery and I'm really very happy to be
here I have a couple of questions before
I proceed with the talk so first of all
how many people here are working in
machine learning and AI okay how many
people here have worked on fairness
particularly alright and any theoretical
computer scientists great all right good
that helps me figure out what I should
be saying all right so this is a
research effort that actually began at
Microsoft's now-defunct Silicon Valley
Lab started in approximately 2010 and I
should mention that all of the good
slides in the talk are due to my student
Christina L Vento so here's our problem
we're interested in algorithmic fairness
we'll be more specific in a minute we
have a population our population is
diverse in many different ways
ethnic diversity religious diversity
Geographic medical and so on and well
whatever it is we want to do we want to
be sure that somehow or other we're
being fair so typical examples would be
something like this we have a bank that
receives detailed user information about
you before giving you your online
experience so you surf on over to some
bank and before they show you anything
they consult with tracking networks and
and find out stuff about you and the
concern and this was a concern that was
raised in a newspaper article in The
Wall Street Journal in a series that
they ran in 2010 called what
no it was mostly about privacy but it
also raised the following fairness
concern the concern was that of the
illegal practice of steering minorities
to credit card offerings of less
desirable terms the financial industry
is more heavily regulated than other
understand many other industries and so
this problem really was a legal one not
just quote unquote a fairness one
so just to dispense with some obvious
things one suggestion is of course to
hide the sensitive information from the
classifier so whether you're a member of
minority group or not would be hidden
and that falls victim to a couple of
things first of all there's redlining
who knows the term redlining great we'll
see a picture of it in a minute and on
the web there's web lining and I'll get
so this is basically say when zip code
is used as a redundant encoding of race
it's illegal to discriminate based on
race it's not illegal to discriminate
based on zip code so we have this issue
now in general of redundant encoding
sensitive attributes can be embedded
holographically in your other attributes
and the other is a sort of birds of a
feather phenomenon so has anybody seen
this picture before this was a an
undergraduate research project at a
class at MIT this is not sort of a
full-fledged studying but essentially
what the students found was the
following if you're male and something
like five percent of your friends on
Facebook are self-described
self-described as gay then you're very
likely to be gay so you may not choose
to release this information about
yourself but from this birds of a
feather flock together phenomenon it can
be determined from the attributes of
your friends so hiding the sensitive
attribute with a little dicey
now there's another problem with hiding
the sensitive information and that is
that in some sense culturally aware
algorithms can be more accurate than
algorithms that sorry if you have a
culturally aware algorithm it can make
very good use of this sensitive
information to be more accurate so in a
typical example and by the way let me
introduce some populations that I'm
going to be using in the talk we all
like food most of us like food some
people like to have their food flavored
with the herbs sage and the rest prefer
to have their food flavored with the
herb time and so my groups are going to
be the time eaters and the sage eaters
and in this generally sage will be the
minority group but not everything will
require that ok so and I'm going to be
calling them SNT so maybe you have a
situation where hearing voices is a very
common religious experience among the
sage eaters but among the time eaters
it's a diagnostic criterion for
schizophrenia this is a real medical
example so knowing whether or not one is
a sage eater or a time eater permits
better classification more accurate
classification ok now as you all know in
machine learning we train on historical
data historical data is often biased and
so we can't just say train on the data
because will imbibe the biases in the
sort of Mother's Milk of training data
and this brings up a really important
problem which is that in general there
there is no general source of ground
truth for the things that we're trying
to do so we have to figure out how to
sort of extract fairness when we
possibly can
keeping this in mind we can't just go to
the training data now who knows what
this is a picture of okay all right this
is a picture from the Sistine Chapel its
Michelangelo's depiction of the Last
Judgement so we have Jesus in the middle
and on his left are the people who are
being condemned to hell and on the right
are people who are going to go to heaven
so this is this is a binary
classification situation you can have a
ternary classification situation so here
we have some slides from brain tissue
over on the left this is cancer on the
right is healthy brain tissue and in the
middle we have cancerous cells on the
left and these cells they're not
cancerous but they're not normal either
they've been they're affected by the
tumor so we might want to turn area more
complicate a classification system for
something like this um here's another
sort of classification problem I'm
calling this a dependent classification
problem so it's let's say that you're
you're trying to hire people your job is
not just to distinguish sort of the
qualified from the unqualified or even
gradations among that you have a more
complicated problem maybe there are
hundreds of qualified people and will
qualified people but you only want to
interview ten of them because after all
you have finite resources so you want to
sort of fairly select a cohort of people
to interview interview so that's a
classification problem where you can't
just classify each person individually
as to whether they're good enough to
interview you have to somehow constrain
it and another kind of classification
problem is scoring now
depend so here this is a when is this
this is something for evaluating
arrested children to determine whether
or not they should be eligible for
detention or release whether they should
be detained or released so it's a
scoring system you can see sorts of
things like there are points for the
various kinds of offenses that they
committed this particular time then
there are other sorts of points for
their prior offense history there are
sort of negative points that come from
mitigating factors and these scores are
then converted into a binary decision
whether to release or to to detain and
depending on the definition that you're
using fairness in scoring will or will
not result in fairness in the in the
decision okay all right because I still
haven't defined anything now we want to
have a mathematically rigorous approach
to algorithmic fairness and historically
there's a way of trying to take these
sort of big goals and translate them
into a research program and that should
lead to some practicable outcome so the
first item in the basic paradigm is
definitions what are you trying to do in
our case this is going to be what do we
mean by fair so one way of doing this is
that you can define fairness by thinking
about what it is you're trying to
prevent so in a good cryptographic
tradition we imagine sort of an
adversary and the adversary is trying to
force unfairness and you want to defend
against this so what are the various
behaviors that were goals that the
adversary may have that you want to
defend against so you define fairness
then what you want to do start with the
definition then you want to define you
know create algorithms and you want that
your algorithms will enforce whatever
this thing is that you've defined so
once we have a definition of fairness
then we want to build a classification
algorithm that will be fair according to
that definition and finally we need a
composition theorem so think about the
systems that you might use that classify
people let's say you're determining
whether they're appropriate for this ad
or that ad right you don't just classify
them once you classify them over and
over and over again for all sorts of
different kinds of ads and many
different times of day and all sorts of
things like that similarly if you're
doing a privacy-preserving data analysis
nobody just wants one privacy-preserving
statistic they want a whole ton of
statistics cryptography you don't just
see one message or one disk digital
signature you've got digital signatures
on tons of different messages and
encryptions of tons of different
messages so you need to prove some sort
of theorem that talks about how these
things combine in practice and those are
called composition theorems so here what
we would want is we would want to say
that if you have a system based of you
know made of fair pieces then the system
somehow is fair in toto so this is a
general paradigm that has been
successful particularly in cryptography
and in privacy so can we apply this to
fairness then the short answer is I
think we probably can but it's way
harder in my experience than in the
other scenarios defining fairness is
very very difficult and very very
controversial it's extremely I don't
believe it's going to be possible to
come up with a single definition that
will be
the technical community can come up with
a single definition that that the
population as a whole would say yes
that's it all right I don't think that's
going to happen building algorithms
that's our bread and butter once we have
definitions there's been a lot of work
already I'm building algorithms some of
it very recent and very exciting so I'll
talk a little bit about that and
composition turns out to be very tricky
and so we'll see a little bit about that
as well so let's talk about defining
fairness I said that we think about what
it is an adversary is trying to do so
think about for example digital
signature schemes what do you want from
a digital signature scheme you know
you're all going to say the same thing
right away nobody should be able to
forge then you have to get into some
details about all of the right
quantifiers about what does it mean to
say nobody should be able to forge but
forgeries are what you're trying to
prevent right so what are we trying to
prevent here so one of the one of our
starting scenarios was actually in the
context of advertising so advertisers
might be biased and we want to build a
platform that will mitigate the biases
of the advertisers and and be fair so we
literally sat around and said okay what
are some of the kinds of things a really
nasty ill intention advertiser might do
so redlining we talked about and that's
that's real redlining in loans was
absolutely real housing loans for
example in the United States there's a
fabulous book you should read by Richard
Rothstein called the color of law which
talks about the effect of the US
government in this biases there's a
reverse tokenism so let's say for
example you know you turn me down for a
loan I say oh you turned me down because
I have curly hair and
they point to Sergei and they say
obviously he's way more qualified than
you are he has straight hair and we
turned him down too
and the thing is they're using him as
the example for all of the curly-haired
people so that's a reverse tokenism and
then there's what I'm going to call
deliberately targeting the wrong subset
of the stage eaters and I'm gonna
actually postpone that explanation in
that example for a slide or two so we we
literally just sat down and wrote a
whole bunch of negative things that we
wanted to try to prevent is this a
reasonable approach well I don't know
another one and one of the advantages
with this sort of approach is let's say
that you build a system that protects
against all these things that we've
listed that's nice and then somebody
comes along and says you missed one you
said great
now you redesign your system to protect
against the new one as well in the
meantime you've been protecting against
these first behaviors anyway so
something happened that was better than
nothing okay so when most people think
about fairness the way I've introduced
it they'll immediately think in terms of
groups and in fact the way I introduced
it was suggestive of that so what are
group group fairness properties are
basically statistical requirements about
the treatment of different groups so
statistical parity which is almost also
known as demographic parenting says that
let's say if we're just doing binary
classification positive and negative it
says the the demographics of the people
with positive classification should be
the same as the demographics of the
general population so these same
proportions are being positively
classified for Sage leaders and time
eaters as in the population as a whole
and also the same for the negative
classifications now this is nice when is
it really really meaningful as we'll see
it's mostly
meaningful in the breach if you see some
incredible departure from statistical
parity that's a red flag it doesn't mean
that things have been unfair necessarily
but it certainly is a nice place to go
looking to see why did this happen all
right so it's it can be meaningful in
the breach but it permits what we call
as I said targeting the wrong subset of
s so I have a spa it's a luxurious spa
and I really don't want those sage
Eaters at my spa but I have to advertise
to them in the same proportion as their
proportion in the population as a whole
so what do I do how do I be biased I
advertise to the members of s who can't
afford to come to my spa so I've
deliberately targeting the ones who
can't come and therefore I'm kind of
ensuring that my spa isn't gaining new
sage eaters but among the time eaters I
advertise to the wealthy and they can
come okay so demographic parity oops
it's not enough and you have to look at
it much more carefully um there's also
this question of sort of the
intersectional cases which leads to
what's colorfully called fairness
gerrymandering so we have our population
I've divided into the sage eaters and
the thyme eaters but there are also the
tea drinkers and the coffee drinkers and
what we may be really want is that if we
look at the four different intersection
categories we should have proportional
representation for each of these
categories right it would be very unfair
if we only showed the ad to Sage eating
coffee drinkers so I mean you can fill
in demographic groups or where you
really clearly want this intersectional
parity and statistical parity by itself
does not protect against this kind of
fairness chair
during so there's another issue which is
that interesting sorry another thing is
so statistical parity was one definition
of fairness for groups there are other
definitions of fairness for groups and
then we have to face the fact that some
group fairness properties are mutually
incompatible so how many of you know
this story yeah okay so many of you do
but most of you don't so I have a
classifier one thing that so so let's
say that we are classifying people and
we are predicting so we're classifying
as to whether we think you're going to
do something we think you're going to
recidivate versus we don't think you're
going to recidivate so importantly here
there's information that's going to be
missing like the future hasn't happened
yet and whether someone released from
jail recidivate smae depend on many
things that happen to them during their
you know their experiences so one thing
you might want reasonably is that you
would have an equal false positive rates
across your different demographic groups
another might be that you would want an
equal false negative rates across the
different demographic groups you might
also want equal positive predictive
value which is among those who are
predicted to recidivate how many of them
actually do that's the positive
predictive value all right
and I chose these three these aren't my
only three but these are very famous
because it's known that no imperfect
classifier can simultaneously ensure
equal false positive rates across groups
and equals false negative rates and
equal positive predictive value unless
the base rate is the same across groups
so unless the base rate of recidivating
is the same across groups
and the reason and the reason for this
as children Chavo points out in her
paper is that these quantities are
related by this equation so we could
write down for the sage leaders the
false positive rate the false negative
rate and the positive predictive value
and they would satisfy this equation
where P would be the base rate in the
among the sage Eaters we would then
write down the same equation for the
time eaters now requiring equal false
positive rates across the two groups
means that the blue terms would have to
be the same in the two equations all of
this this term would have to be the same
in the two equations so then these blue
guys have to be the same and that blue
term would have to be the same and the
only way this could happen is if the
base rate P is the same in the two
groups ok now so no algorithm when the
future is unknown so therefore
classification would be imperfect no
algorithm can simultaneously ensure
these three very natural desiderata
unless the base rate is the same and
nobody cares how that algorithm is
implemented so if you believe in free
choice or randomness you get the same
thing whether the algorithm is a machine
or whether it's some other form so it
does not make sense to say let's solve
this problem by bringing a human into
the loop does nobody you could bring
into the loop that would address this
problem
ok it's just the math ok so as you can
probably tell I find group group various
notions
I'm dissatisfying for a number of
reasons I mean shared some of these
reasons with you now this brings us to
very famous video how many people have
seen this not all great I mean not even
half so this is an experiment with
capuchin monkeys they're paired up the
monkey has to do a task which is to hand
you a rock and then the monkey gets a
reward so let's see sorry so she gives a
rock to us that's the task and we give
her a piece of cucumber and she eats it
the other one needs to give a rock to us
and that's what she does and she gets a
grape and see each of the other one sees
that she gives a rock to us now guess
again cucumber
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay so that brings us to a notion that
I prefer which is individual fairness an
individual fairness says intuitively
that for a given classification task if
two people are similar with respect to
that classification task then they
should be treated similarly now to make
any sense out of this we need the right
notion of what it means to be similar or
dissimilar we need some kind of a
distance notion so a classic example is
in credit scoring where the difference
in credit scoring literally gives you a
metric for how how dissimilar a pair of
people are considered to be for
creditworthiness okay now and of course
again I have to emphasize this is a
task-specific notion so Sergey and I
might be in fact comparably qualified
for a loan but for recommending hair
products who would be completely
different
so we're similar for one purpose but
totally different for another purpose so
it's very important that when we talk
about these metrics there their task
specific now thinking about credit
scores may be you know people in general
are sort of smooshed uniformly from
highly qualified to very unqualified so
that so that if in fact you sort of soso
so when you're trying to decide whether
to give a loan based on whether somebody
crosses a threshold you may have two
people who are very close and you give
one of them the loan and you deny it to
the other one right and if the scores
are in fact sort of sort of densely
packed along this line then indeed that
has to happen so sort of have to draw
the line somewhere that's the general
worry then you would have very similar
people who are being treated very
dissimilar ly so what did the
theoreticians say they
you should do in this case you
randomized so instead of deciding yes
definitely for you and definitely not
for you you assigned to people a
probability of getting the loan or a
probability of getting an A depending on
on their their creditworthiness and and
you arrange that if two people are very
similar than the probability
distribution on outcomes that they see
is very similar yes
two policemen were just fired for the
skin tossing the coin to decide whether
to arrest someone for a speeding ticket
so there are circumstances under which
it might be the right thing to do police
have huge amounts of discretion and if
they treat similar people similarly
maybe that's fine instead of scaled
alone so instead of having a fixed
amount that you lend you could change
the amount of loan till it you know
reaches which is zero you could
certainly do something like that I would
have to think through all of the
ramifications but there are cases where
you must make a binary decision so so
we're going to take this as our
definition of fairness so we have a set
of outcomes in this case it's yes and no
that's Oh this is the probability
distributions on outcomes so we want to
find a classifier that map's
individuals in our universe to
probability distributions on outcomes
with the following condition for some
appropriate measure of the difference of
two probability distributions for
example total variation distance we want
that the difference in these
distributions will be bounded by the
distance of these two individuals so
it's a Lipschitz considered
the distance under the appropriate tasks
specific metric now of course this
immediately says where does the metric
come from how are you going to get your
hands on the metric and I don't have a
great answer to that but I also believe
that if we actually had a classification
system that people thought was fair then
we could extract from it a metric or yes
yes that's exactly what I just said you
don't know where to get our hands on the
metric so when we did this work
initially we said that at the very best
it was going to be society's best guests
at the moment and clearly what we would
need I'm now understanding more and more
that these things are going to be
handled by political processes that
there's no other way of getting these
things other than combining stakeholders
and measurements to get somewhere but we
don't have a straight mathematical
answer for where we're going to get the
metric yes
the attention between who watches the
Watchmen Sun of argument over repeat the
best person to decide if I'm going to
offend you it's you not me and in terms
of individual furnace is it to be the
case that if society or dictate that
we'll come back into a group furnace so
for individual furnace the toughest nut
to crack is that the source of a metric
warming is the subject to which the
decision will be applied us in the case
of the monkey the monkey was the one
decided this is not fair right so any
hands as to how to I don't anything
rather the other societal and individual
fairness or separating them properly so
I don't have a mathematical answer to
that yet and what I'm starting to engage
in very
heavily now is what is the right way of
thinking about it and politically and I
don't mean political correctness I mean
political theory and ethics but I I it's
it's an unknown and you know work on it
guys there's it really makes sense it's
an important problem maybe ask me more
about anything are we right people so
not by yourselves unless you have a
whole very broad education but so so you
know inevitably these there's going to
be legislation and regulation we have to
be sure that what gets legislated and
regulated is not technically stupid that
it's not infeasible and people will say
you know I think there's a real risk of
very bad law and regulation so I think
that the technologists have an important
role to play in in helping to steer away
from that also I think that
technologists sort of hearing more about
the concerns and the issues are they
have they have some of the tools needed
to try to move those can act on those
concerns so we are sort of but not by
ourselves you know yes how do we know
that the metric is even computable for
example if the brain is a universal
trait missional then there can the can't
exist computable function that maps
remain a mystery machine it's good any
arbitrary mission to a computable number
so I'm hearing about two-thirds of your
words but you seem to be saying how do
we know that it's computable in the
sense of how do we know that information
is available how do we get our hands on
the information which would give us the
metric as in this if you if you suppose
that a brain as unit was a treat machine
okay and it executes any arbitrary
machine that no computable possible can
map from a university machine to a
metric right util metric
so I'm not sure what hard what decision
problem you're trying to work in here
like whether the brain stops on itself
when it gets itself as I just I don't
know exactly maybe ask me after I'm
sorry okay I'm gonna go on let's talk a
little bit about algorithms so first as
he said these are challenges with which
we are familiar so in the ad setting we
imagined a situation where we actually
knew our universe of individuals and we
even gave the advertiser the opportunity
to say for each individual in each
potential outcome how bad is it for this
individual to be mapped to that outcome
so what's a loss that's associated by
incurred by mapping this individual to
outcome oh and then with that it's just
something that we are adding optionally
to allow the vendors to weigh in on
things and then we assembled the
ingredients of the science-fiction
metric and they vendors loss functions
we want to minimize the vendors loss
subject to the fairness conditions so
we're viewing the loss functions as soft
constraints and the fairness conditions
as hard constraints and this is just a
linear program so in theory this can be
solved and in fact there's an
interesting observation which is sort of
evocative of those theorems about what
you can't do when the base rates are
unequal if you solve the fairness linear
program you get a classifier that gives
you a statistical parity if and only if
intuitively the the the distributions
are the same so the earthmover distance
between the uniform distribution on the
sage eaters and the time eaters is zero
now recently so that was something where
we assumed that we knew the whole
universe very recently Roth Blauman
have shown how to relax this a little
bit to what they're calling probably
approximate fairness and then they get
generalizability we didn't we didn't
generalize in our initial result so
that's a 20-18 result now I mentioned
that there's been a lot of progress in
recent years so for example heart price
and shrub row took equal false negative
rate and equal false positive rate and
optionally also equal false positive
rate as a fairness requirement and they
showed how to convert unfair predictors
to fair predictors income not for
individual fairness their notion of
fairness is these groups that's these
group fairness and something that I
think that you guys might appreciate is
they did this all in post-processing so
as you know if you're trying to get a
product group to use one of your tools
it's much better if you don't have to
interfere in their pipeline and you can
stick something at the beginning or the
end so that's something they did then in
other work Joseph Kern's Morgenstern and
Roth looked at a different problem they
were looking at a bandit setting so you
have basically one arm for each
demographic group so in our example
there would be two groups but it could
be more general and they're worried
about the fact that you may have a lack
of training data for your for your
minority group so for the sage eaters
you don't have a lot of training data
and what they require is that at each
round let's say think about this in
terms of loan at each round one person
from each demographic group comes and
you have to choose one to give a loan to
or at most one to give a loan to and
maybe what you'll do is you'll actually
choose a probability distribution and
you'll then choose somebody from that
distribution and the requirement
that a worse applicant will never be
favored in terms of these probabilities
over a better one despite uncertainty so
they study how to minimize the regret
and learn a fare policy so they want to
they look at the difference between the
regret that you get when you enforce
this kind of fairness condition which
basically costs you while you were
learning about the minority group once
you know that minority group well you
can predict with confidence but when you
don't can so they show that there's a
gap that it's more expensive you have
higher regret when you're learning a
fare policy versus regret when fairness
is not a concern there was a question
there using individual fairness at each
round among the people who have shown up
at that round actually no sorry they're
doing something a little bit more flips
just that a worse applicant is not
favored over a better applicant yes
sorry yeah I misremembered that's the
run for this paper yeah okay so there
was 2016-2017 was a really interesting
year so two independent groups of
researchers started looking at some of
these things similar questions so now
we're getting into the intersectional
case that I mentioned before so imagine
that you have for the first paper this
is where the gerrymandering nomenclature
came from imagine that you have a couple
of sensitive bits for now let's say Kay
sensitive bits so sage versus time and
coffee versus tea and a couple of other
sensitive bits this gives you 2 to the K
subsets suppose all of those subsets are
still large they're not tiny relative to
the population as a whole then this
first so this is sort of large
intersections of large sets all right so
they're handling the intersection or
they're studying the intersectional case
and they want to learn a classifier that
will essentially ensure well they looked
at a few different notions statistical
parity and equalizing the false positive
or false negative rates across these
intersectional sets and they so I
described it as being defined by say K
bits all of the subsets of those K bits
but you could have other ways of
describing your collection of sets like
a set of all all the sets that can be
described by small circuits so as long
as the set is largely sets are large
enough they want to try to guarantee
these notions of fairness across the
groups they also showed that the general
problem of what they call fairness
auditing is hard so I give you a
classifier and these descriptions
perhaps implicit of these groups how do
you determine whether there is a group
whose doing you're being unfair when one
of these intersectional things to whom
you're being unfair and they showed
hardness by reduction from agnostic
learning so the reason they can have an
algorithm as well as these negative
results is as you all know machine
learning often does interesting things
even when in theory they're hard very
similar questions were looked at by a
Bird Johnson Kim Ryan golden Roth
wait I made a mistake
this is Roth Blum the other one is Roth
this is Roth Blum and they studied
calibration so suppose my-my-my
predictor is now giving a score and so
I'm going to rate people some number
between 0 & 1 think about this as my
prediction about your probability of
recidivating for example so the system
is calibrated if among those that are
rated v the fraction who truly will end
up with a positive label is close to V
so in other words it's requiring
correctness on average for those rated V
for all V so they got results
that were very similar but they're using
this kind of notion of correctness as
fairness through the the calibration
version if you're familiar with the
Kleinberg mullainathan and Raghavan
results this is the kind of calibration
notion there or it's related to their
calibration notions and they argue that
this is makes more sense than these
other group fairness notions but other
than that they get very similar results
so for every set defined by a circuit in
a predetermined set C they get this
approximate calibration simultaneously
and subsequent work by Michael Kim and
James O has has shown that this has been
they've used this to improve some
medical predictors and they've they've
gotten some nice results okay and then
what how long is my talk okay I'll talk
for just a little more then okay so the
next batch of results deals with
algorithmic work that tries to bridge
the gap between group fairness and
individual fairness by assuming that we
have some sort of Oracle that tells us
for we can we can ask about certain
collections of edges and say what are
the distances on these edges and then it
leverages that to do powerful things
without requiring you to ask about all
pairs in the deep learning community
there's a whole different approach which
is adversarial learning or learning of
fair representations and adversarial
version of that so this is a group
fairness notion oh shoot sorry the all
right I'm gonna skip this slide okay so
we're gonna the general idea here is we
start with instances in some set X and
we're going to
learn a new representation for people
that in some sense retains as much
information as possible while
suppressing some key attributes such as
whether somebody is or is not a member
say Jeter when there say Jeter or a time
eater and the they're using gams and so
we've got an adversary that is trying to
distinguish given a Z whether it came
from the say Jeter X or a time eater X
and the key point in this the intuition
is the predictor is going to operate on
the representation Z if the predictor is
known not not so powerful as the
adversary who is trying to distinguish
say Jeter's from time eaters and who has
trained the encoder to make that
representation not yield
distinguishability the predictor is no
more powerful than a than in some sense
it's predictions can't be biased this is
really really intriguing it is a group
notion of fairness and I would love to
see individual fairness worked in here
but this is a you know another very
interesting direction of research so in
the last five minutes we would talk
about composition because this is really
interesting and this is new so our
intuition is if we have a system in
which we have a bunch of individually
fair pieces then when we look at the
system that's made of these as a whole
it's still at least relatively fair and
the answer is it's complicated
so here's a very simple example suppose
let's make the example really simple
you're looking at the New York Times
website and there is a single slot for a
banner ad at the top of the page okay
that's going to be our scenario
well as you know there's an auction run
for your attention advertisers are
competing to get that slot so let's look
at the case where we have two kinds of
advertisers one is advertising tech jobs
and the other one is advertising a
grocery delivery service so the tech
jobs advertiser and the grocery delivery
service advertiser are competing for
their attention
and we want that we you know ideally if
our classifier for determining who is a
good shot a good bet for the tech jobs
ad is fair and if our classifier for
determining who's a good bet for the
grocery ad is fair then somehow the
system will be fair as a whole but we
want to require that in this complex
system it's still the case that people
who are similarly qualified for tech
jobs should be similarly likely to see
tech job ads and same thing for
groceries so suppose that the grocery
advertiser routinely out bids the tech
jobs advertiser it's an auction the out
bidder wins so we can even think of it
as just the out bidder goes first the
grocery advertiser is going first or
it's bidding more all right
and so the tech company is now
essentially being reduced to the
leftovers the ones who weren't grabbed
by the groceries advertiser this is true
again whether it's done temporarily
first one than the other or whether it's
just done by the money bids so you know
this is a major problem it says that no
matter how qualified you are for a tech
jobs ad if you're very qualified for
groceries you're not going to see the
tech jobs ads now who is qualified for
the tech for the for the grocery service
the grocery delivery service new parents
advertisers drool over the things they
can start advertising to new parents and
those tend not to be the tech jobs
advertisers and in fact the tech jobs
advertisers you might say shouldn't
touch the Parenthood bit with a ten-foot
pole
so even if they're really appropriately
not looking at Parenthood status you
would think it was appropriate not to be
looking at Parenthood status in
determining who should see the ad
they're competitors for your attention
are looking at that and that's affecting
what happens under the tech jobs
advertiser okay and and there are
versions of this particular problem both
for individual fairness and for group
fairness so this problem doesn't go away
um no time for these things there is a
way out here though which I will mention
which is we could fix a probability
distribution on the advertising tasks
any probability distribution we want
then we pick a task according to that
distribution and then we run the
classifier just for the chosen task and
the proof that this gives us fairness is
individual fairness is very very simple
but it leaves money on the table because
there are some people for whom we are
just not going to be showing ads so that
raises a number of very interesting
economics questions for those who are
interested in the intersection of
algorithms and economics and because of
time I will skip the rest Wow final
comments
first of all interpret ability and
causality there are big literature's on
interpret ability and causality for
fairness why is this slide left blank
first of all I have tried very hard to
to make headway with interpretability
and I have failed I don't under
and what's being asked and how it can be
achieved there's a very interesting
article called the mythos of
interpretability by Zachary Lipton and
he explains he sort of catalogs these
are some things that people could want
and here are some of the issues it's
very very thoughtful and I'm not done
thinking about this but I'm stumped on
this one as far as causality it's
problematic for a number of reasons that
I can say so first of all if you're
using say pearls theory of causal
reasoning you need a generative model
now maybe you're familiar with the
saying that all models are wrong but
some models are useful so if your
definition of fairness ties the
classifier to the model and if you know
you need those two together to determine
if something is fair and your model is
wrong you may very well come up with the
wrong conclusion so that's a glimpse
into what some of the difficulties I've
encountered with with with causality are
and they're yeah okay another brief
comment as we've talked about the metric
we've talked about the issues of where
do you get the metric from even if we
sort of there's still there's still
problems so here suppose we have a news
organization nice news and your news
organization has an environment there's
randomness in the environment you have
an individual X there's randomness in X
but you can sort of talk about although
you can't get your hands on the
probability that an individual X this
individual X will succeed in the new in
the in at nice news its well-defined
once you specify the coins for this
randomness and the coins for this
randomness again you can't get your
hands on it but at least it makes sense
mathematically now what you might
require is that if
two people are similar meaning they have
similar probabilities now in success and
success can be very crisply defined like
you stay in the company for at least
three years and you have at least one
promotion during that time okay so if
you haven't you might say that if you
have two individuals who are sort of
equally likely to succeed then they
should have very similar probabilities
of being hired okay so that seems to
make some sense so the metric then is
capturing the probability of success but
what happens if this is not nice news
but it's nasty news which has a history
of being very hostile to Sage eaters so
sage Eaters can't succeed no matter how
talented they are or they'll have a real
uphill struggle so should the metric in
fact be capturing whether people are
equally likely to succeed should it be
capturing whether they're equally
talented you know what's the right thing
to do here it's not clear so final
remarks truth is elusive it's not remedy
this problem is not remedied by having a
computer and if you and I really as I've
argued I really believed that metrics
are really at the heart of everything
even if it may take us a long time to
find them but we advocate always
sunshine for the metric the metric
should not be kept secret it has to be
open for debate and discussion and
refinement computers are not necessarily
worse than humans they may be more
accurate especially on the easy cases
they may be more easily tested they
don't get tired when you keep throwing
examples at them to see what they have
to do that's it thank you
[Applause]
sure go ahead sorry I'm behind and there
is this terrible you know sage rush at
all the city just made anyone we need
sage get very ill we have this terrible
historical injustice right all the sage
eaters they just did way less good
virtually everything they're so focused
handling this illness right so it just
so happens via this sort of historical
coincidence
the sage eaters are almost never like a
similarly situated individual to be able
to compete with the time eaters it seems
like on that individual fairness metric
we would just say okay no problem
I mean it's weird design jobs and it's
the time meters that get all of them
whereas we're not considering that sort
of group aspect and I think there's some
analogues we could make you know certain
societies so that's of course an
excellent point and in the paper we
described what we called fair
affirmative action which is a method for
dealing with this where we break certain
of the Lipchitz constraints for exactly
this reason and but it's a it's a
principled approach to this sort of
thing and I should mention that it's not
so unlike what the state of California
does and the state of Texas does with
respect to college that if you're in the
top 10 percent of your class then you're
eligible to for you you're admitted to
one of the state in California it's one
of the UCS and in Texas it's one of the
state colleges I guess and and the point
is that schools in different
neighborhoods may have very very
different performances on tests and so
on and so forth but it's the same basic
idea so we add a bit to that it's not
quite of course as taking the top 10%
there's a very interesting work by John
Romer at Yale who is very concerned with
you know theories have distributed just
a distributive justice and he thinks a
lot about education he thinks that you
must invest and invest in invest in
children in order to compensate for
differences of of situation and that
sort of as you go through the schooling
process you do less and less of this
compensating because the children having
been given a good foundation are more
theoretically I guess more more more
responsible for how they make use of
what they have but in particular I
remember he said the following in the
context of college admissions stratify
the students according to the education
level of the mother and within each
stratum look at the cumulative
distribution function describing how
many hours a week the students spend on
homework and view people in the various
percentiles in that CDF from the
different strata as being comparable and
one of the points he makes which I found
extremely compelling is that if you're
if you're brought up in a home where
nobody is educated then you may not even
think that it's possible to spend 10 or
15 hours a week on homework it just
doesn't cross your mind to do it or you
might be working and unable to do it
so I
that these sorts of insights from the
social scientists are very important and
what we are doing is in some sense
analogous to that yeah it's a very good
point yeah
yes conversation is basically related to
this nasty news choosing your metric
thing right and it kind of comes down to
questions of what what you want to
condition on and mediating variables and
stuff and so and basically the rest of
the talk didn't address those those
kinds of issues right like how to choose
the metric fairly is is there any work
that that uses you know graphical models
or other ideas for causal inference to
kind of cuz meetup is intuitive idea of
oh well we should condition on these
things we want to make a fair metric but
we definitely don't want to condition
these other things is there any is there
any work that tries to formalize that
there is work there are so especially
like okay so yes there's work it's very
interesting and if you're interested you
know I can point you to a bunch of
papers the one difficulty with some of
this work is that you can have the same
sort of observable distribution on data
that's consistent with very different
causal models and so that can well that
just causes problems so I don't know
what to say about that yet I was really
excited when when I sort of saw that
there was a counterfactual fairness
paper I thought yes this is it this is
it but then we found two different
models that give rise to the same
distribution and we and the classifier
and the thing was fair under one and not
under the other so what do you do you
know yes yes so suppose they want to get
adjusting for every school I want to
select the chess team of three people to
represent my school or some company
and so what do I probably do define
measure how good the people are and take
the best rebuy my
and it seems like by your definition of
individual fairness the more accurately
I can measure people the best randomness
there is and the less fairness um
you introduce the randomness for your
son read you think that the algorithm
introduces them there are members I mean
if you just stick like what people
typically do they're not going to
introduce happiness out of the fat but
there will be randomness and because
some people win some people lose there's
randomness and how well you can act
measure people's skill and so it seems
like by your definition the more
accurately we can measure people's skill
the less randomness there is the less
fair selection process so if you're
saying that you can get very very very
like maybe we're gonna buyers why is a
completely random process more fair than
America Matic one right okay so this is
the kind of problem that shows up in
fairness all the time I mean you you
you've sort of for the from this
particular example you've sort of hit
the nail on the head so in the
definition of individual fairness I mean
it buried in there is the idea that if
you simply flipped coins all the time
that would be fair if all you did was
decide whether someone could be on the
chess team by flipping a coin certainly
similar people would be treated
similarly what we're not ensuring is
that dissimilar people are treated
dissimilarly so this is where we want to
throw in they will minimize the lost
subject to the fairness conditions and
we want to incorporate some notion of
loss in the decision process so we want
to stay fair but we also want to
maximize utility fairness constraint is
to be random
so I I know what you're saying and you
can probably come up with even better
examples of where randomness is unfair
or we're treating everybody the same way
as unfair and often it's possible to
kind of reframe the problem so that
you're pushing those concerned into into
the objective function rather than the
fairness by the way we thought that we
were so original with similar treated
similarly but of course Aristotle says
the same thing and Aristotle says
dissimilar should be treated dis
similarly since we were thinking
initially about advertising and I was
thinking about how when you look at a
physical newspaper you know everybody
gets the same ads it has nothing to do
there's no targeting so that seems
pretty fair and and in terms of like
exposing young people to ads for luxury
goods does that help form aspirations or
not should you be saying that poor
people should not see poor children
shouldn't see nice things or pictures of
nice things so there are people who work
on these kinds of questions from the
psychological and sociological point of
view and they think that yeah it's the
ads are very tied in with the
formulation of the self and that having
a real difference in what people see is
harmful so yes individual metrics I was
thinking about drug treatment effects
and where you're doing these randomized
control assignments and you're thinking
about theories of population let me find
someone from this other population that
matters well see the treatment effect
when
different really I can imagine a dual
sort of problem here where you really
want the classifier to behave like a
placebo for these matched individuals
rather than as a drug with some
treatment effect and that actually boils
down not to the individual fairness
where you're assigning this metric on
every pair of individuals in the
population but only like across groups
right and then you you do a lot of
medical crises within a group but you
want placebo Ness across groups so this
is really interesting and I don't know
so I mentioned that in the causal sorry
yeah in the causality literature there's
been work sort of in the pearl model but
in the Rubin model I don't know of any
they may be there but I don't know of
any and I want to look at that so I
think this is you know this is
definitely worth thinking through so
very good question great I was wondering
about something so the title is about
this going towards a theory of marbling
fairness I was thinking have people
tried to turn it around and say that we
are going to accept that things are
going to be unfair and we want to
actually quantify the degree of how
unfair things are in other words either
I'm treating them as fairness
constraints trying to put them into
maybe equivalence classes of like the
way people study like program classes
and say Kotzen yeah any thoughts in that
direction I only know of one theoretical
result along those lines which when I
was talking about when individual
fairness implies statistical parity in
fact there's a sort of tighter
characterization of how unfair it is in
terms of the earthmover distance between
groups but I don't know
I guess some of the very recent works do
look at what happens if you relax things
a little bit like that probably
approximately fair notion
so you're saying okay well introduce a
little bit of slack what could we get
from it so there is some of that but I
don't know a sort of wholesale saying
okay well we're just going to treat
these people this way and differential
privacy there's this trade-off of some
you're somewhere in like somewhere on
that curve right you give up privacy to
get more accuracy if you yeah so if you
think about it the definition of
fairness is very similar in flavor to
the definition of differential privacy
but it it doesn't behave the same way
under composition and yeah there is one
result also about using a particular
algorithm from differential privacy to
ensure fairness where again
where the trade-off that you talk about
would would perhaps be relevant yeah
anyone else yes so this problem is
complicated you've given it pretty
beautiful summary of the related work
and talking about how it's gonna take a
long time to reach maybe consensus maybe
not but some legislation on this at the
same time computers are not necessarily
worse than humans and people are trying
to put mission learn models into the
world in different domains right what is
your prescription about what needs to be
done right now do we stop and wait until
we really understand these things better
do we apply some reasonable approach
because something is better than nothing
what is kind of the practitioners guide
of what needs to be
so I feel wildly unqualified to answer
that question but I'll try anyway so
even if I thought and I don't even if I
thought it was appropriate to wait
that's a non-starter in the business
world Facebook is not gonna stop you
know just you just cannot stop industry
where it is I think just yeah the
political forces are way too strong now
what you can do of course is start
creating test sets test sets where there
are at least the people who create the
sets believe they know what the outcomes
should be and so so for example
algorithmic assistance in bail
determination right the it's happening
in many states I can't remember the
number in shorts at least 12 but I can't
remember why that number is in my head
so it's happening in a lot of states so
one thing that we would work I don't
know how useful it is to see the code
because you know code can be hard to
understand but certainly you would want
that somehow appropriate people in
organizations should be able to throw
test cases at the algorithm and see what
it does so I would say really intensive
monitoring with the best golden sets you
can come up with and lots of people
doing it I think that's where we are for
now okay because monitoring you can do
yeah
yeah so if you just do what people are
doing and try and maximize your accuracy
and release these algorithms in the wild
are there any instances where it's clear
that it went bad
where is quickly where it's clear that
the algorithm has gone bad oh yeah lots
of cases uh speed bump is that what it
was called Street bump I forget so um
pothole detectors that will report to
the municipality about potholes but this
was an app on an iPhone and so the only
areas that got the reports of the
potholes for the wealthy areas that's an
issue where it's not as accurate like
the people are making that app we're
like a team we're after and that's what
they're trying to understand if the app
isn't being brought over the right
potholes if it's not if it's not make
penetrating into the poor areas of town
it's just not giving you the information
you want the system as a whole is unfair
so you're saying is there a
classification algorithm like the others
like the minority group in which it has
less data and so it's less accurate this
is I I mean when it I'm not sure that it
was inaccurate where it was it just
wasn't coverage there was no it was lack
of coverage maybe I'm gonna go ahead and
want to provide an example yes sir so
compass wait you're gonna start with
compass yeah with compass is that they
were test fare right for those criteria
but they weren't for or positive and
false positive or negative er yes but
they were test fare and it's impossible
to simultaneously be test fare and have
equal false positive rate
so so I'm looking for one where it's
clear that it's unfair by like if you
like talk to a random person on the
street that's very clearly so Oh College
Admissions good college admissions as
well
college admissions and wealth is
probably a really good example so the
derivative action is but controversial
right this is part of the issue remember
I began the talk by saying that there's
consensus at least there's more
consensus on privacy than there is in
fairness so it is affirmative action
fair what do you think there would be a
range of opinions here
as to whether it's fair or not
have there been examples historically
that news classification algorithms that
were very biased yes the answer is yes
we talk about fairness and
classification it seems like some
classification problems are less
important than others for example if
you're trying to decide what ad to show
someone that's a problem but Carens
trying to decide which person to kill
this guy's so here's what I think we
should do about the cars is that if this
your question or not well I mean
what are you gonna say all right so for
a while I thought oh my god we can't do
anything until we figure out what's
right to do in our situation and then
thinking about the cars I thought well
suppose you have an algorithm that what
it what you do is you learn what do
everage people do maybe you use the
moral machine for this maybe you have
some other way of figuring out
statistically but you learn what sort of
a random person would do and then your
car driving algorithm should do the
following when it gets into one of these
really touchy situations it should do
what a random person does and the rest
of the time it should just do its
automated driving so this would be much
better than humans because in all the
usual situations it'll be more accurate
and in the really wacky ones it'll be no
worse than humans so altogether it's
better you say oh what a random person
would do what does that do you mean like
I mean I think one way that this might
like one intuition is that everyone's
equal so there's Lois what around we do
you so what's some probability
distribution and you just draw from that
distribution and you do what that person
does is that shifting down the problem
like one view switch mode so I was
thinking and I was thinking that it
would not be difficult to know when to
switch modes that most of the time was
totally clear what to do and then
sometimes there was a moral question and
then you see you you go to your database
of what would people do and you consult
that so it also subjective which is rain
for societal biases a huge step like a
motor biosample as people are biased
even if you pick a random that's good of
you bias decision okay sorry last
question
go ahead so it seems like a lot of this
comes from just you know
they are said that because this
compromise that Finals problems are
frequently buyers like recidivism there
said that people tend to be arrested at
higher rates you know even even compare
what people so that base rate already
starts off being ice so maybe like a
income example for points like maybe you
don't see so many women CEOs and
therefore if you are trying to do a more
than where you're pretty thing pay it
has to be fewer highly paid women
historically so you don't even have that
data in the first place right so it
seems to me that there should be some
you know some kind of work just working
in the data space um you know trying to
maybe host in a what fraction training
day that would look like there are for
setting those there are efforts that
involved what I would call massages
training data
exactly as you're suggesting um I don't
know how to put them on a sort of firm
theoretical foundation but people have
thought about those sorts of things yes
as you say they sort of Hulu you could
hallucinate some data to change your
training set I don't know a lot of work
on doing that and how you would do it
but I guess I mean now that you mention
it you know statisticians do this sort
of thing all the time when they when
they wait their samples so something
maybe could be doable but then you have
to decide you know how are you going to
do that waiting it's like the Reuben
virtual fairness approach what was it
Reuben style counterfactual finals so
not not personal but roommates though
you would be trying to weigh up the
women's the euro cost
she's very rare NZ hope so when you
actually train on it you weigh up the
women see you over there anymore and you
you know them but I'll pass these
courses to find that wait yeah so it's a
as I said I think it's a really good
idea to try to pursue that direction and
see what it gives there's a nice image
okay good all right thank you thank you
[Applause]